(audience applauds)
Well, if it isn't time for Drew's News.
Your daily good news ravioli,
stuffed with three types of good news cheeses.
Yum.
And it's pasta week this week.
(Ross laughs)
I know.
And I definitely comfort eat.
So this is just perfect.
And with me at the desk is my trusty co-pilot,
Rossy Ross Matthews.
(audience applauds)
Yes, happy pasta week.
Hi, everybody.
All right, well,
this story, I was really excited about.
Because this new "Elvis" trailer is out.
Oh my God.
And the king is back.
And Vogue is reporting
that we've got our first peak at the trailer,
and it's directed by the incredible Baz Luhrmann,
who did "Romeo & Juliet,"
which I think is just an absolute masterpiece.
And "Moulin Rouge,"
and the movie traces Elvis' whole life,
from the very beginning to the very end.
And the King is gonna be played
by this young actor.
His name is Austin Butler.
And he was sort of on some Nickelodeon shows,
and kind of went that route through his life.
He started around 13.
He beat out all these interesting people,
like Ansel Elgort and Harry Styles.
And then Tom Hanks plays Colonel Tom Parker.
And he's the real life manager
who sort of plucked Elvis out
and really changed the trajectory of his career.
Mm-hmm.
And we have a little clip from it.
Let's take a look.
(upbeat music)
I wish to promote you, Mr Presley.
(camera flashes)
♪ The warden threw a party in the county jail ♪
Are you ready to fly?
I'm ready. Ready to fly.
Tomorrow, all of America will be talking
about Elvis Presley.
(indistinct)
(audience applauds)
Ah huh huh.
When you see that clip,
we were like, you know,
how did he beat out all those other people?
Uh, that's why, right?
He's so, "Uh huh huh."
When the reviews come out, don't be cruel.
Uh huh huh, huh huh.
(audience laughs)
Man, I should've gotten the part, right?
I think Elvis might have been
the hottest guy I've ever seen in my life too.
(audience applauds)
Did you see him in... ?
No.
Oh, not in person?
No, I never saw him in person.
But like, he was a religion.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean, people like, you know,
everything was Elvis when I was growing up.
And you know, the whole story,
when you think about, the young Elvis,
then in the army, and then how he sort of changed
into Vegas Elvis.
I mean, that's quite a journey.
Yeah, I get it.
(audience laughs)
And it's your story, Rossy.
Well, it is.
Talk about movies coming back to the theater.
"The Batman" finally hits theaters this Friday.
Everybody is talking about this movie.
(audience applauds)
You know, we've seen the Batman before,
but this starts it all over again.
With Robert Pattinson as Batman,
Zoey Kravitz as Catwoman,
Colin Farrell as The Penguin,
and Paul Dano, who's an actor you're gonna remember.
You'll know him, as the villain, The Riddler.
And these past Batman's like Christian Bale,
they've been known for that deep, gravelly voice, right?
Mm-hmm.
Well...
I was laughing 'cause I was picturing myself
doing the Batman.
By the way,
say "Deep, gravelly voice" again, Rossy.
But I heard it come out of me,
"Deep, gravelly voice."
(Drew laughs)
I was picturing like, you know, if I was upset
I didn't get the role of Elvis,
can you imagine me as Batman?
(Drew and audience laughs)
Well, okay, so I'm not the Batman,
but Robert Pattinson is,
and he recently revealed that he tried
a completely different voice
for the first two weeks of filming.
I think he was maybe doing me.
(Ross laughs)
No.
(Drew laughs)
It was more of like,
a whispery kind of voice.
And he said it was so atrocious,
that they asked him to stop.
He said they said, "You gotta do something else."
So he went with something more conventional.
And we actually have,
here's a listen to Robert Pattinson as the Batman.
(intense music)
What are you hiding?
Selina, don't throw your life away.
Don't worry, honey, I get nine of them.
Justice. The answer's justice.
He sounds good, and early reviews,
I've been reading online the early reviews,
are like, "This is like no Batman you've ever seen before."
It's getting very, very good reviews.
Who is gonna go to the movie theater
and see it this weekend or any time?
Mm-hmm.
A lot. Okay.
Well, I guess they made the right call
in putting it in every theater in America then.
(upbeat music)